carlos going to the mound for his 24th
start looking for his 13th win carlos
rodon is the center of attention here
tonight as he will face cincinnati in
his final start before the postseason
1-2 that one varied in the czech swing
and india is down that's a better slider
that's a much better slider that's a
really good sign
center field it's robert
for round number two
3-2
lifted towards center
robert on the move luis and adam and
it's luis sunny gray goes to the mount
for his 26th start era touching four a
lot of strikeouts 149 at 130 and that's
what he's going to use and he kind of
spreads it around first pitch
nice pick
one down
another pick by suarez
two great gloves to begin the game
and he goes down swinging sonny gray
some help from suarez but pitch
efficient and carefree
bottom two no score for the white sox
and red
check swing he went
that's two k's for gray
all of that aggressiveness on the
breaking ball is set up by that second
fastball that he ran right in on the
hands of ximenez
oh beautiful pitch
oh sonny gray is having fun tonight bro
down to max schrock and he hits a high
one out in the left
shallow coming way in is
he'll make the catch
larry garcia has on number two
in the left center
robert is over
and he makes the catch six up and six
down so far for sonny gray in this ball
game scoreless bottom of the third
inning hit on the ground toward right
and it's off the glove of a diving match
shrock
and it's an infield hit for garcia kevin
sheets batting with a man on nobody out
gavin drills his ball he's done it again
the power of gavin sheets
two nothing socks
that's why he was throwing in curveballs
[Applause]
but then he decided you know what i
think i can sneak a fastball by him
didn't work out all that well as gavin
just tattoos his 11th
he's driven in 30 and this young man got
his opportunity this year and makes the
most of it
aquino on the fly
one down
and down on strikes that's four k's for
sonny gray
center field barrero
after sheets goes deep gray sets down
three in a row 38 pitches for carlos
rodon
to right center robert on the track and
it hit his glove he actually got there
it goes rolling around the track and
stevenson's going to take two bases
luis robert actually got to that
baseball but couldn't squeeze it
on the warning track
there is number seven and strikeout
number three
when you haven't seen a lot of them
they're really tough to deal with
robert again
in center field
stevenson won't tag and two gone 2-1
high fly shallow center luis robert
again
he
gloves it they get their first hit a
lead off double the stevenson never
advanced to third here's jose good
timing against sonny gray
jose abreu
just got hit
for the 22nd time
unfortunately he got hit literally on
the same elbow literally in the same
spot
curveball strike three grand all goes
down in the fifth strikeout for gray
towards second india thought two goes to
one
3o misses down that's fall four two on
two out and garcia
into center field that drops down
here comes pizza around third and the
sox add-on garcia
after the first pitch on an rbi single
that's 54 driven in and this is that
drifting fastball
sunday gray got a strikeout on it
earlier that's one that he throws at the
right hip of a left-hand hitter and it
drifts back over the plate
there he didn't give up on it he's two
for two and his remarkable season just
continues to roll along two on for
sheets who hit a two-run homer his first
time up
into left field and down another
fastball another gavin sheets rbi
it's four-nothing socks what a series
for gavin sheets
well gavin uh last night did a similar
thing he's hit to left field
driving in a run
i mean you don't know what approach he's
going to take he's taking you deep to
right one second and then hitting the
other the other direction he's just
showing some brilliance with the thought
process so 51 pitches right now for
carlos rodon three four plus one pitch
in the fifth
struck him out slider down to 78 slow
version and one gone that was actually
his back door get me over slider that
wasn't the back foot wipeout that we've
seen many times but it's still equally
as effective
bloop to left eloy charging and he does
get there for round number two
swinging a high fly ball who wants it
left field it's gonna be
alloy rodon through five is not allowed
to run tonight the sox have taken a four
nothing lead on cincinnati here in the
fifth
as there's a line drive to left for
robert it's a one-out single as there he
goes on the pitch throw to second is
late robert steals second
jose taps it out in front of the play
little side spin and sonny gray goes to
first robert into third
and two down
this one bounces away off of stevenson
here comes robert and the sox add
another it's five nothing that's
something else you can't really teach
and that is great anticipation top of
the order the aggressive tim anderson
who's over three
tim in the air to right field a wall and
out
spaghetti dinner tonight
six nothing socks
that's 17 of them and 59 driven in they
had stayed away from him the entire
night hadn't thrown anything inside it
was just
outside outside outside and now tim got
a high fastball and he rides it out of
the park top of the ninth inning and
there's that man number 48. mike wright
comes on for the 13th time adam engel in
right
now number one
luis robert
one more catch for him two down
shields to right angle won't get to it
wave is on at third base farmer shoots
home and the reds avoid the shutout
stand up rbi double by delano de shields
it's six to one so tony wants to get
crochet a look at a right hander here in
the ninth inning
left side
oncotta
and that will do it sox win at 6-1 and
take care of cincinnati in back-to-back
days